sal a gas de la parecía que volvía hoy a
alterar el curso de este proceso que
apenas lleva dos días comenzó temprano
reclamando cuando vamos a escuchar a las
víctimas de siria y dijo que en su
barrio de molenbeek en bruselas y muchas
víctimas como sus amigos dice gente
solidaria que le ayudaron sin saber lo
que estaba planeando y que hoy se
encuentran tras las rejas como él en ese
box ultra custodiado de este proceso del
13 de noviembre el juez ya limpiar y el
presidente de esta corta un hombre muy
experimentado que justamente realiza el
último juicio de su carrera le cortó el
micrófono le dijo usted ha tenido cinco
años para hablar nunca lo ha hecho hoy
no es el momento estamos viendo un tema
técnico con las víctimas civiles que
conversamos creen que el juez tiene la
experiencia suficiente para controlar
los arranques de salas de slam de hecho
hoy el proceso continuo de manera
tranquila con el análisis de esas nuevas
víctimas civiles que quieren
incorporarse a la lista de las víctimas
de este proceso son personas que quizás
no fueron tocadas
y hueso por las explosiones por los
ataques pero que se sienten también
víctimas la lista definitiva la
tendremos en octubre mañana es un día
importante porque el presidente de la
corte va a leer el informe que hizo tras
leer la investigación de este proceso
quizás hay informaciones que ni las
víctimas ni la prensa ni los abogados ni
la opinión pública conozcan